I'm a scared flyer and this movie did
not help me at all no so this was uh
this was a tough one for me
I'm just curious which one of you guys
are the better flyer and do you have any
tips for me
I I don't fly I mean I fly but I don't
fly the plane
um I I've grown to love planes because
I'm a person of statistics and no matter
how crazy it is supposedly planes are
still the safest way to travel so um
until it otherwise proves otherwise I'm
gonna I'm gonna take the plane there's
more chance of us both dropping dead of
a heart attack right now yeah I don't
know if that's true but uh but you know
we had a choice to call this movie plane
or putting the airlines finally out of
business so we thought we'd stick with
plane I can't say this does not normally
happen on flights you know you don't
normally end up on a on a remote Island
full of rebels so no don't worry okay
okay I'll take the fact into account uh
Gerard I'm curious you play uh Captain
Brody Torrance in this one did you have
to get any pilot training going into
this or did they just throw a bunch of
terms at you that you said to repeat
yeah I just sat in a seat and said tell
me what buttons to press
um no that's not true no I did I spent a
lot of time in a simulator because I you
know for me one of the fun things about
this job is you know you're playing a
submarine Commander or a secret service
guy is to really climb into it because
you're you know curious as a person
anyway and also so that you're not
standing there just pretending you
actually feel like you know what you're
talking about whether whether I'm
actually using what you know messing
with the auxiliary power unit or or you
know or the electrics of the plane it's
good to know how everything works and
then we ran all the sequences hundreds
of times both in the simulator where
you're actually and it's very real like
you're flying around La looking to land
the plane on the 405 and the 101
um or in the actual cockpit the mock-up
that we did which moves a lot you know
it was crazy being in that it's like a
roller coaster ride I was on a gimbal so
it's just you're it's throwing you all
over the place
um and um had a lot of time to to
practice in there
I love that that's a lot more intense
than I thought it was going to be I
thought you'd just be in some kind of
you know simulated plane but uh yeah
it's intense
um Mike I'm curious I I'm sorry um your
character progression throughout the
movie you start off as a kind of a
mysterious quiet guy and then all of a
sudden you're running around the jungle
tank top sweating profusely with a rifle
around your neck did you have to channel
some inner Rambo for this role or how
did that go for you you know there's so
many there's so many things that this
movie does for for that character and
for the development of a relationship
between Gaspar and Torrance it's like
you start off and I remember in costumes
we were just talking about wardrobe you
were just talking about what was he
wearing and and and like my eyes
gravitated towards this rose-colored
shirt and I don't know why because it
was like the only thing the first time
you see the character what is he wearing
and I thought out of all things they had
I'm like this rose-colored shirt has
some softness to it and he's these are
very I don't know why the characters
don't you start that's a secret and so
you know but then eventually that that
shirt comes off and it's like okay now
we're in it and and one point I'm glad
we didn't make this choice I was
supposed to tie the shirt around my head
because it was hot and it was really hot
let me tell you it was really hot I was
like I was afraid to be out there with
no no hat on because it's so hot but it
was a really tough rugged shoot and I
think the jungle really helped to sort
of get us in the characters because you
can't fake heat like that you can't fake
you're tired all the time you can't fake
you're climbing up a mountain and trying
to get I hate fake breaths you know like
trying to be I'm so tired we just were
we were tired we were hot we were sweaty
and we were it was we were tough at it
and I think that that Puerto Rico did
that for us and and it really plays on
the in the film
yeah I love that yeah you can't you
can't fake he can't sweat a fake sweat
so it was authentic which I love
um yeah that's all the time I have right
now guys uh congratulations on the movie
and yeah have a great rest of your day
thank you good luck flying
[Music]